I remember visiting my aunties,
my uncles,
my grandma.
And the smells.
You know they're the most important things in my life the smells.
Certain tastes that you remember.
So that's what I remember from my childhood.
Before - you know before things got black and nasty.
Those are the happy times.
What do you miss most?
Who did you leave behind?
How do you feel about yourself now?
Is it quiet inside?
Or do you always remember their voices?
So what do you remember most?
Everybody had to sort of turn their radios off.
You couldn't listen to the radio anymore
and everybody had to 'shush shush'.
If they were talking about- everybody had to whisper.
My mother pushed me under the bed.
And she started to pace
up and down past the bed.
And I was under the bed so I could see.
There was a little rug where she was pacing,
but she was pacing further.
And I started to see hair on this rug.
She was tearing her hair out.
I thought: 'What's happening? What's that?'
Anyway, sooner than later, we heard big footsteps coming up
the wooden stairs, the nice apartments.
And I heard a lot of heavy wooden steps.
You know? They- they sound funny on wood.
Just not the same as on carpet or stone.
And they were heavy.
They came knocking on the door
and we didn't answer. They knocked again, banging.
And we heard the door being broken with an axe.
You know, the lock and the doors,
just bashed in with an axe.
And French police among Gestapo came in.
A Gestapo is a special SS man.
He's an SS man really.
He represents the man who gave the orders.
And the man who gave the orders came from the top is Hitler.
And the next one is Eichmann.
Eichmann was the man who put all his signature
to all of these arrests in Paris. Eichmann.
Who do you think of the most?
What was your favorite memory?
Do you miss her?
Do you miss him?
Do you miss them?
We had to go at night very furtively Madame Colombe and me.
And she took me to say goodbye to my grandparents
just before they were arrested.
And I said goodbye to my grandparents.
She left me there for about, I don't know, an hour.
Because we lived, literally across the road, literally.
And I remember sort of asking - my grandfather,
he was a traditional old Polish gentleman
and he had his little - I had only little I call it a yarmulke.
But people call it something else.
I can't remember the name now the English name,
but it's a ££
And he had a very long white beard.
Long and then you know, all these hair and this white hair.
I remember snuggling into my grandfather and smelling him.
And smelling his beard.
It had - It's really strange
because when a child has a sense of smell, it's sharp.
It hasn't been spoiled by anything like smoking
or the things to get in the way so you can smell
Everything. And you could - it was sort of
it wasn't a dirty smell, he'd washed it - I just -
I can still smell him. He smelled of age and food.
What does it feel like, to be the one still alive?
And sometimes when I was younger,
I had this terrible what they call now survivor guilt.
I lived with that till I was way, way, way, way way in my 40s.
The survivor guilt. The same question that goes in your mind.
In your nightmares, day and night, day and night:
Why did they take me and leave my parents behind?
Why was I left behind?
To live a, you know, a sole life
without anybody around me that I knew.
Why, you know, had this cruel thing happened.
And I didn't want to be, I didn't want to be.
Because I just felt it was too cruel.
I didn't actually understand.
I couldn't override the fact that I was very lucky.
I couldn't see that part.
I could only see it at a later time. But at that time,
I think the survivor guilt overrides everything else
and the happiness always is below the surface.
So all you see is layer of survivor guilt and no happiness.